[Musique]
j'ai rencontré des jeunes entre 18 et 24
ans et on a discuté des questions que
les écoles discute pas souvent avec g
comment expliques tu ta position
concernant l'arrivée des réfugiés
pourquoi tous cherchent que pour
l'information concernant le sujet des
réfugiés
comment interpréter la propagande en
ligne contre les réfugiés
quelle stratégie média ou messages
utilisés par la propagande en ligne tir
de l'attention et te fait réfléchir
comment réagis-tu face au comportement
propagandistes comment interpréter les
réactions de toutes entourage face aux
messages partagés en ni par les
propagandistes
comment expliques tu t'es interprétation
d'où vient-elle
comment fais-tu face au racisme comment
fais-tu face à ton propre racisme
comment discuter des perspectives avec
ta famille et tes amis
si tu savais d'avancé qu'ils vont les
opposer si tu avais la chance de
t'engager dans une contre confiante
qu'elle serait tombée
comment percevrait tue tout rôle dans
cet contre-propagande qui serait en
ambiance qui se retourne comme quel
serait ton plan d'action est ce que tu
te soucie assez pour agir qu'est ce qui
te motive qu'est ce qui te retiens
comment veux-tu éliminer les éléments
qui torrentielles
est ce que tu te sors assez confiant
pour agir et pourquoi
[Musique]
la recherche propose un modèle avec des
outils concrets que les enseignants et
les travailleurs sociaux et même les
parents pourraient utiliser avec leurs
jeunes pour les impliquer dans des
discussions en profondeur et
transformative concernant des sujets
sensibles et controversées telles que le
sujet des réfugiés à travers mes
discussions les jeunes participants à ma
recherche ont réalisé qu'il devait
toujours commencer par se comprendre et
comprendre l'autre que le dialogue était
la solution non pas l'étiquetage ni le
lancement des propos haineux et que leur
voix comptées alors ils devaient arrêter
d'agir en spectateur passive et
commencer à participer aux discussions
qui a affecté leur vie et notre société